口笛~♪
いやぁ、こんにちわ。
今日もようこそ  《 クラブ・はじめ 》  に来てくれたね！  お嬢ちゃん？
感謝してるよ？
ワタクシ、　ホストぅを務めとぅります
と言います。
以下、よろしく
ま、僕ぐらいのホストィングになると
世の中の、様々なお酒、
飲み物、ジュース、カクテェレ
いろーんな飲み物を、飲んできたわけさ
飲み物の味の  味の違いが  すぐ 分かっちゃうわけさ
と言う訳で今日は、お客様の皆様に
この、ホスティングはじめの
素晴らしぃ～  特技を、
みせて、あげるよ？
うぇ、、気持ち悪い
さあ、早速注文してみよう
いろはす  一丁！　ﾌｯﾌ～♪
『いろはす  一丁！　ﾌｯﾌ～♪』
いろはす！いろはす！いろは、、、違った、ホストってどんな感じなの？
ま、とりあえずね？いろはすっすすよ
ご注文ありがとうございます！        いろはす  入りました～
フッフ～
みんな知ってるか分んないけども、物知りのはじめ君は解っちゃうンだよ？
いろはすはね？実は何種類か種類があるんだ。
ちなみに、この  いろはす  は、
山梨県、山梨県の方の、何でいうんだろう？
「きた」   ヤベ、読めねぇ。な、なんて読むんだろう
しら、しゅうちょう？
きた、しゃし、し、、、漢字辞典一丁～
いろはすもう一本入りました～　フッフ～
こちらの いろはす は、富山県、砺波市・・・
俺の地元だ、地元じゃん
いろはす追加入りました～
フッフ～
いろはす、あー
こちらの いろはす は鳥取県のいろはす
こちらに今三種類のほろ酔い、じゃねーや
三種類のいろはす  が準備してある
全部で７種類ですね、
静岡県に住んでるけどなぜか静岡の  いろはす  は、無いよ？ごめんね
いやぁ、あの、探したんですけどホントに無くて
山梨
富山県
鳥取県
俺たちがいつも飲んでるイロハス、
全部で七種類あることが分かった
そこで俺は考えた
この天才ホスト君のはじめ
この俺に掛れば　イロハス　の水の違いなんて
一目瞭然
君達とは、飲んできた量が、違うからね！
フッフ～♪
と言う訳で、今日の動画は
ホスティングはじめ、この三つの違いをバッチリ当てるんで
観ててくれよな？
♪！！
まずは、イロハスの味を覚えよう
まずは鳥取県のイロハスを飲みます
♫ どんどん？ペリぺリ～どんどんペリペリ～
あ～優しい味わいだ
鳥取のイロハスは、こう、何だろう？
鳥取砂丘を思い浮かばすような
砂漠の奥地で取れた、オアシス
そう、君の瞳の様にね？
君の瞳の様なオアシスの匂いが感じられた
ﾀﾏﾝﾅｲね？ （口笛）  ♪ ～
山梨県イロハス入りまーす　フッフ～
頂きます、　ドンペリ入りまぁす！　ﾌｯﾌ～
♫ どんどん？ペリぺリ～どんどんペリペリ～
これはまさに最高峰の水に近いね？
日本最大の山、富士山のごとく
top of the world　この世の全ての山の頂点に君臨する、
エベレストには及ばないが、ナンバーワンよりオンリーワン
君の事さ！
づついて最後、俺の地元の味
こちら、富山県のイロハス。
地元のイロハスは特に味の違いが解ってると思うべイビー
♬
富山県の イロハス 入ります！　ﾌｯﾌ～♪
♫ どんどん？ペリぺリ～どんどんペリペリ～
タマンねーこの味わい
富山県の、豊かな大地を感じるよ？
ホタルイカの様に、キラキラっと輝く君の瞳に・・・乾杯
♬！
はい、と言う訳で全ての違いが分かった所で、
今からこのイロハス三つの中で
俺の地元の富山県のイロハスを、
バシッ！！  と当てちゃうぜ、君の目の前で
富山県のシャッフル、　富山県のシャッフルじゃﾈｰな
おおーっとごめんよ。言葉のアヤがからまっちゃった
富山県のイロハスを当てた時点で
俺は、トップオブ・ザ・ホスティング・ベイビー　ですからね？
今宵も  はじめんティーに  来てくれて  ホントにみんな  ありがとう
では、これを飲んで行こうと思います
んんー
うめーな
これではないと思う、　多分これではない
こっちの二本のどれかですね
解ってしまったよベイビ
富山県のイロハスは
これだ！
当たった！え？まじで当たった
ホントに当たった
ほら、ほら？富山県、まじでまじで、え？まって
マジで解るんだけど
Party people
でもな～
実際のトコロ、全然わかんネｰな